Hello and welcome everyone. This is
ActInf livestream number 51. Two.
It's November 9, 2022.
Welcome to the the active inference
institute. We're a participatory online
institute that is communication,
learning and practicing applied active
inference. This is a recorded and an
archived livestream, so please provide
us feedback so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome and we'll be following video
etiquette for live streams, head over
active inference.org to learn more about
participating in different institute
projects. Alright, well,
we're in act imp stream number 51.2.
We're in our third discussion on the
paper. Canonical neural networks perform
active inference from 2022.
We had a dot zero video with some
background and context and overview.
And then last week in 51.1 we had
a great discussion, went over many
interesting details of the paper and
related topics. So today we're going to
jump in, cover some empirical details,
some implications, connect some more
dots, maybe look at some code. And
thanks again to Kuya for joining these
discussions. I'm Daniel, I'm a
researcher in California and thought a
lot over the last week about what this
kind of neural network synthesis
or translation really means,
and just want to learn more about what
fundamentals or foundational aspects
of these different kinds of models
enable that synthesis or translation.
And then again what that means for areas
where one or the other kind of model is
already in use. So thanks again for
joining and I'll pass it to you if
you want to say hi or give any a
second interoception. Oh yeah,
I'm appearing Brain Science Institute,
Japan. So I look forward to
discuss another different aspect
of this work.
Well, let's just remind ourselves of
the fundamental parallel being made
in the paper and then we'll get to these
two questions about kind of the two
directions that things can go.
One representation is in equation one
with loss function of a neural network
and the free energy on a POMDP.
And that's also seen visually in figure
one, with a neural network being drawn
a concordance against the variational
base of the action perception loop. So
maybe just let's begin by restating.
What is this parallel that is
in equation one and figure one and
how was it reached in this paper?
So basically idea
here is that we
derived to characterize the dynamics and
activity of canonical neural network in
terms of Bayesian inference, because
arbitrary dynamics of neural network is
interoceptive in the sense that we don't
know what is the function underlying
such a dynamics and what is
the coherence of the
self organization or activity.
So once we translate that
dynamics in terms of Bayesian, we can
assign quantities
in Bayesian for any biological
quantities, which enables us to lend
the explainability to the neural network
dynamics and architectures. So that's a
basic idea. And what we have done
in this paper is that we
consider a biological plausible cost
function for this particular canonical
neural network. And show the equivalence
between that Costa function and the
variation navy energy and the particular
partially observable cognition process
model.
Awesome. So let's look at the parallel
between the cost function for neural
networks and the informational free
energy. So one representation of that
was in figure three. So maybe
could you just describe what is the
structure of the informational free
energy expression and what is the
structure of the loss function?
Okay, so there is a clear parallel
between the functional structure
or those component in informational
free energy and component in neural
network Costa function. So let's say the
first time in F correspond to
the it correspond to the
expectation about hidden states is
a hidden states Australia.
So that part basically indicates
the free energy with respect to the
hidden state. Yeah, and the second part
correspond to the free energy about the
decision posterior. So the indicates
the posterior belief about agent
decision or action.
And now in
terms of the correspondence between the
free energy and neural network function
here the first time in the neural
network function correspond to middle
layer neural activity which has
a recurrent connection and receive
sensory input from sensory layer and
then project the
output to the output layer and
the second term correspond to output
layer which receive signals from middle
layer and send the feedback
response to the environment.
So both of us expressions
have the first term being more like a
cognition perceptual sensory learning
term and the second term is more like
a control theoretic action selection.
And how did you see this
analogy or concordance because it looks
like a zipper, like everything is
totally lined up.
Well,
this graph itself showed a clear
correspondence because now we
are considering a particular form of on
DP in which each element of
hidden states takes either zero or one.
But there are many states so
it is expressed in a form of
factorization. So now we
consider that in terms of the
s fosteria Bordeaux. Upper part
of Bordeaux correspond to the
expectation about each element of s
taking one and lower part of
the bordese correspond to the
expectation about s taking zero. So it
is broke vector about the posterior
expectation and this nicely
correspond to the Brea
vector shown in the bottom up this
figure it is a vector
of x and Bijan
sorry it is a vector of x and by x
and here by x indicate one minus x in
the element y sense which is
exactly correspond to block
vector or expectation.
This correspondence also
observed in the second tab.
Here, log S correspond to log X
and also log
A correspond to the broke matrix
of W log W.
Here W hat indicates
the sigmoidal function of W and its
bar means sigmoidal
function of W. So actually,
because we now consider binary
hidden state and binary observation
it's like reviewed mapping. Mapping from
hidden states to conversation is
expressed as block matrix, which is
exactly correspond to broke matrix shown
in the bottom of this figure.
So like this, for every tab
we have the exact correspondence between
the upper expression and the lower
expression.
So that's why we can say that this is a
natural mapping from neural network
formation to parishional vision
formation.
So it speaks a sort of identity between
those two different expressions.
So although 1 may be able to consider
another mapping from neural network
to Bayesian inference, this is a
sort of simplest mapping.
So how would it look different if it
were three states categorical
distribution or a continuous
distribution? What aspects would change?
Thank you for asking that. So that's
in some sense outside of this paper
because only when we consider a
binary hidden state,
this analogy is established
nicely. Otherwise we need to
consider some attention. So because
consider that each neuron code
the probability or expectation of some
value taking one, then the probability
or expectation of
taking zero can be simply
computed by computing one Ines neural
activity. So actually neural activity
which is a single dimensional variable
is sufficient to express the
expectation. Right? But once we
consider the three state hidden
states program,
this doesn't work. So we need to
consider at least two variables
but it's relation to neural
network expression is not very clear in
general.
That's very interesting why it
would be so strong of a concordance
in a binary case but immediately
unclear for other distributions.
Yeah,
generally for poem DB expression we
consider the one hot
expression, one hot vector expression
which means that we normalize the value
in the sense that the summation of all
variable to be one.
Maybe there is some neural substrate
that achieve that communication.
But for classic
type of neural network like canonical
neural network, consider in this paper
what is that neural substrate
is not very clear. So that's why we
selected the binary case because it's
simple and have a clear
analogy. So what does it mean for
an artificial or for a biological
neuron to have activity dynamics
or plasticity context?
That justifies it being described
as playing like a belief role
in a Bayesian setting.
Higher firing means more belief, higher
firing means lower belief. What does it
really mean to have a connection between
in this episode of street talk belief
states. I see, so if
you assign a mapping, a particular
mapping, then its meaning is also
determined. In this case,
we assign that neural activity
correspond to the posterior
expectation about an element of
hidden states taking one. So once we
define this mapping, then higher neural
activity indicates the higher
probability of taking one.
So neural activity is the probability
neural activity is on the x axis and
the y axis of the sigmoid function is
the probability of taking one.
Well. Neural activity
encodes the expectation. So neural
activity is sigmoidal function
of something itself.
This is because once we see a fixed
point of neural activity equation which
is derived from this cos function, it
has a form of sigma WADA function so x
equals sigmawilder function of graph,
graph, graph. So this form is exactly
correspond to softwaremax
function of something which is seen
in the solution of possibly expectation.
That'S what the neural activity encodes
and what is the Bayesian interpretation
or the update rules on the plasticity.
Okay, that's another important point.
So in terms of posture
of parameters so in the case
of Bayesian force us we consider update
about deleted parameters of
a matrix and B matrix which is usually
expressed by the small case
variable. And its
meaning is that if
we compute the partial derivative of a
partial derivative of F with respect to
small A then its solution it's
fixed point solution looks like an
computer product of which
is also known as Hebbian product
because it has an errors drink to
update depending on the precinaptic
neuron activity and postsynaptic neuron
activity. And according
to this formal equivalent we revisit
we can see again such analogy
in a formal sense here if
we computer the partial derivative of
neural network function with respect to
W then
we can formally derive the Hebbian
prosthesis which depends on
the activity of prey and postsynaptic
neuro activity.
Okay, so hebion plasticity
often described as neurons that fired
together, wired together. Here you're
discussing it in terms of a matrix
operation on the POMDP side between
observables and hidden states.
So there's a hebion plasticity happening
between the perceptual layer
and the cognitive layer,
right? So the first half
of the neural network is trained
according to heavy and plasticity rules
that optimize the A in
terms of the perceptual and learning
like relationship between hidden states
and observables. And then the
second half of the neural network has
a slightly different structure. It is
optimizing based upon retroactive
re analysis of consequences of action
according to the fictive causality
construction.
So actually in
this figure b up layer
correspond to environment and lower part
correspond to agent. So this structure
corresponds to figure eight,
this correspond to a simpler version of
foam DP. So for version of POMDP,
its corresponding neural network is
showing figure four or this paper image
task. This is the neural network
architectures.
So as you say, there is a network
connection from sensory layer to
cognition layer which is expressed by W
here and recurrent connection which
corresponds to state transient matrix is
expressed by K matrix which is
recurrent Sinematic connectivity.
And as you say the action generation
through retrospective reward
or risk evolution is done by output
trigger through the synaptic
connectivity expressed as V in this
figure. So V is
the synaptic connectivity between
cognitive states in the middle layer and
the action selection states in Y.
Exactly. And so in that way V is exactly
analogous to W. But why and
how does gamma come into play only in
this second layer? I mean why not have
gamma one in the first layer? Gamma two
in the second layer.
Generally speaking, it is possible to
moderate plasticity in first layer
using another moderator gamma.
But for complexity we focus only on
neural modulation in the output layer.
Analogy is that for
example, as you said, the first rigor
computer more perceptual things
so perception of external world
and instead on
the other hand middle secondary
which is mapping from cognition
layer to action layer perform
the optimization of its own action.
So for example,
in the story item in
the brain action prediction is optimized
by conversation of
dopamine as a input. So usually
that socket receives signal from
ecological neural socket and send
signal to another neuronal
nucleus in meat
grain. But the point here is that neuron
in storatum encodes some decision
for examples goal or no goal.
So such a decision is encoded.
So now we consider analogy between pond
DP expression in the Bayesian
formation and neural socket in
the brain that optimize
action through some sort of
moderation by another
factor. Here that factor corresponds to
gamma and gamma
has variety of function.
But in this paper we focus only on the
moderation of activity.
So here the behavior activity is not
determined by only a preposter
relationship but determined by three
factors relationship in the sense that
the activity is updated by the
product of gamma and prayer and
postsynaptic activity.
So there are three times in one.
This is why this comma can moderate
prosthesity.
So how would a glial factor look
different computationally? And where in
the brain have people identified levels
or other factors as relevant for
learning? Yeah, that's an interesting
point. I'm not really sure about the
equation of the real moderation of
neural activity or plasticity. There are
many discussions and I'm
sorry, I don't know the exact form,
but one possible implementation
is similar to this type of
neuromodulation. So it
would be possible to model
some real
contribution or free factor to
plasticity in the form of three factor
learning room which is mathematically
speaking Lamme as this type
of neural moderation.
Here in table two we have another set
of correspondences. It's like a sideways
figure three, right? But a little bit
more like a dictionary.
Anything to add? Or any variables that
we haven't really mentioned. What about
the firing thresholds? Because these are
common parameters in a neural model,
however, we don't really hear
about the interpretation of
these constructs within the variational
base POMDP.
Yeah, there is an interesting
story.
That's a very interesting point. So when
we first tried to make
analogy between neurons network and
one program is the
law of threshold factor because as you
said, it is not absorbing POMDP
structure. But there is another
factor in Pompey which is
prior expectation about hidden state
which is usually expressed by D matrix.
And what we consider is
the relationship between d matrix and
firing threshold. And finally,
what we found is that firing
threshold is not equal to the matrix
itself, but it is a summation
of B matrix under some function
of synaptic
strength or which is equal to
a matrix b matrix in the POMDP
formation. In other words, what we found
is that each which is
a firing solution in neural network
architecture,
it is actually an adaptive
threshold which is not a fixed
value, but h is a function of
W sinatic strengths
and h changes depending on
W's value. For example, if W is too
Laje, then your activity can
be unstable. So h behavior
to reduce the activity to make
neural activity more stable.
So we can see an analogy
of omeostatic mechanism here.
If we design A as
the function of w and function
of another factor which is all
part of the term in this table, then we
could make common analogy between this
h and some variable in
palm DP correlation which is shown
in the right hand side of this table.
Although its value is not
simple because it chaos three
different tasks. So all of them
contribute to make
h or M.
But anyway, once we
map, so once we establish a mapping
between h and this value,
then everything works. So the
cost function in different settings
have Omar correspondence.
H and the M firing thresholds.
So H correspond to middle rare M
indicator output raider threshold
which are different variables. And
interestingly h correspond to prior
expectation about hidden states because
it corresponds to community rare and M
correspond a priori belief about its
own action because it
is a bias in the action layer.
Yeah, it's very interesting that the
perceptual firing threshold h only
includes prior beliefs on hidden states,
beliefs about how observations map to
hidden states A and beliefs about how
hidden states change their time B. So
that's like pure passive inference.
And then the firing thresholds for M
correspond to only beliefs
about preferences and beliefs about
actions or habits with C and E. So
there's like a complete division of
labor or partitioning functionally
between these structurally different
parts of the neural network and
structurally different and functionally
different parts of the POMDP.
Yet they're integrated in unified
loss functions or unified imperatives.
And so it's like there's extreme
separability of perception and action
on both sides of the figure one divide,
but also they're
integrated, but they're separate. And
that's what kind of grants it the best
of both worlds because if they were any
more integrated you couldn't really pull
them apart. And if they were any less
integrated then the imperative, the loss
function or the variational free energy
would be ad hoc and unprincipled.
But there's kind of a middle ground
where they have a principled integration
but still a distinguishment.
Right? This is caused
by network structure defined or
it is because the
structure of Bayesian
network defined in the MDV model.
So both of them define the
causal relationship between elements or
quantities.
Its substrate is not important,
so it's relationship is crucial
to determine the cost function or it's
a fixed point in this context. So that's
why we can see the
data analogy.
Well, there's a few technical
points I think we can now go into and
then there will be some more general
points about applications and
intelligence. So first the
code availability statement. Awesome to
see that the MATLAB scripts are
available and also active on Zinodo.
So here is the GitHub repo
for reverse engineering. Do you want to
give any overview descriptions of what
people can expect to see in this repo?
And also what about using MATLAB?
Why did you use MATLAB? What advantages
or limitations do you see in MATLAB?
So, because this is a very simple
simulation, so Macrab
is sufficient to encode the whole
script.
We also try some implication in
the material. See here,
if you run the script, then you
can see the process of
an agent solving the maze task.
What did they do in the maze task?
So here the aim of this
agent is to reach
the right hand side of this maze.
Because this is a typical example of
the rate moderation task. That's why we
select the main task.
So to achieve this next task, is it
required to make some plan to be
able to select a good decision?
Because without planning,
you may encounter the war and cannot go
further and you may fail
the image. But with learning,
it is possible to see the path to
reach the right hand side of this space.
So does it know its exploration?
Yeah, it received a state from
neighboring eleven times eleven Jelle.
So which is shown in the bottom part.
Yeah, this left
figure C indicates the observation.
So eleven times eleven state around
the agent position. Okay.
Now agent is on the right hand side of
image at the goal position and it
observes our neighboring state.
Well, a few interesting things here.
It's looking off the right end.
Yeah. And it has this kind of periodic
belief in the key distribution.
Why? I think
it is because when
the agent is in the middle point
of maze, then all
neighboring state is in the maze.
So there is a
path and there is a wall. So this makes
some ergodicity because mazes
have some structures and actually have
a periodic structure and
only at the goal position, then right
hand side becomes war.
But it is not common
for this agent.
This is because this agent show
such a priori pattern.
Yeah, the streets are one wide and
they tend to be separated by one.
So we see this periodicity. What is the
numbers in this middle bottom plot and
what does the checker board represent?
Yeah,
hered correspond to
possibility, expectation about active
states and decision. So middle indicate
decision posterior and decision.
Here we characterize decision as
a secret of four step actions.
So each action correspond to a
movement to right
or left or up or down.
And we consider a four step sequence
of that option which is expressed as
D. So it has
four power,
four possibility.
256. Yeah,
256. So this is a protein
on XY coordinate
because in the
middle panel, middle point correspond to
the current position of agent. And with
four step movement, agent can go one
of any current position and
the current brightness corresponds
to the expectation about
the agent decision. Well this is very
interesting. If we just were to think
about you're at a point and you can go
up, down, left, right, you have four
moves. Naively it
sounds like, well it should look like a
gaussian blur. Most of those should
cancel out and then it should become
rarer and rarer monotonically. But
actually you start in the middle,
you can't end up on these white squares
because it's like one, two,
three and then you have to leave.
Right? So it's kind of like horses
in chess or other pieces
where actually their embodiment,
it's very unexpected that you can't in
four moves end up next to where you
began when you can be so much further.
And then we see this kind of like
embodied inferential prior with QS
that embodies regularity beliefs about
the width of the road and the separation
of the roads. And then there's these
like embodied action priors and
real consequences that have to do with
the structure of movement.
So what it's doing? It's thinking about
policies of length four. There's 256
policies of length four. There's some
degeneracy because there's obviously not
256 squares here. So while only one
policy is going to take you up, up,
down, down, other squares
are reachable. Like the center square is
probably the mode because it can be
reached at least a handful of
ways. And then
at each time point it's basically saying
okay, I know where my X position is
and given my local eleven by eleven
view, I'm trying to
plan to go right.
And then here through time in the
simulation here it starts at 30
something, it quickly figures out how to
get to about 40 and then it's kind of
going up and down on 40. But it can't
really break out because all
of these bottom four routes are closed.
It has a breakout and then very quickly
it hits another plateau around 60.
Right. Then it kind of has
a very nice breakout and in just a
few steps goes very far.
So what is dopamine doing? Or how is
Dopamine helping it in the plateau and
then to break out of the plateau?
Yes. So this agent
learned this particular structure
through many trials. So before
training it failed to reach the goal,
but after training it achieved
such a nice behavior.
So to active this, the role of domain
is that we design gamma
function such that if the
agent can move rightward with
some distance during some time
limit, then risk becomes small like
say comma equals zero nor risk
situation in that sense. In that case,
this agent updates synaptic weights
through hebion frostbust.
But if the agent failed
to go rightward with
some distance during a limited time
frame, then gamma becomes large
like zero six which is
larger than the average zero five.
Then we design
that drawing in attention
antihebian prosthesis occurred instead
of Hebbian. So antihabion
indicates the works as the
disassociation between the current state
and current decisions. Because the
current decision does work, it's not
good decision. So we
try to make the agent who will get
that particular decision rules
through conversation of heavy and
plasticity done by Dharma factory.
So this can be an
arrow to the Dopamine moderation heavy
and activity. So if the policy
is resulting in the expected outcome,
gamma stays at .5, the policy is
as risky or consequential as expected,
and then the policy can either go better
than expected, which facilitates
learning to support that decision. To be
made more or the outcome of the policy
can be worse than expected, which
disassociates previous conceptions to
discourage that kind of behavior.
Exactly. Crucial point is that
this association with different time
frame in the sense that we consider
multiplication of current risk and least
decisions to average over
past two present Hebbian
product. This makes an association
between past decision secrets and the
current risk which enables to optimize
decision to minimize the future
risk. It is just a safe time frame.
So here risk is being used in
a formal sense similar to how it's used
in economics which is the
associated uncertainty of outcomes with
respect to a policy.
Where does danger come into play?
Like what if there was an adversary
in the maze or something that was
dangerous? How does this kind of model
accommodate or hunger or
different kinds of competitions?
Because right now it's basically just
trying to diffuse right word with a
bias. Right? But how do
different kind of situational elements
become interface into the generative
model and generative process? Okay,
any of those factors
can be involved in risk factor,
a single risk factor. So you can
arbitrary design and risk factor
because risk factor moderate
generative model. So that's why agent
try to minimize the risk through
basic embryo updating. But the risk
itself is in some sense outside
of such a Bayesian framework.
So we can design
arbitrary risk. So it may involve some
danger factor,
any other factor.
And this simulation,
it is a POMDP or
it is a neural network. And what scripts
might we look at to understand the
structure of the maze agents? Okay,
it is basically expressed
using the quantity in home depp
for tractability. But for example, if
you see the MDP
learning probably okay,
there is a variable Lamme
type in
the definition of SIM type
correspond to the type of simulation.
So if it's one or two it becomes
homo DP or neural network to
my understanding. Well,
in this particular example,
Jelle, we use the
let's say maybe
it's not good example that DeForest
is learning the deforesting
this script as well. So maybe
another as an example,
let's see.
What is MDP init is initiating
the markup decision process. Exactly.
It's just determining the initial state
of the computer generative model
fe compute variational free energy or
risk MDP computer risk
function. So basically
we use the neural network structure
computation in this particular setup.
So when you click maze
m then in
the line 31
line we determine that Lamme type is
two. This correspond to neural network
architecture. So there is
a very slight difference between home
depicture and neural network
architecture because assuming
neural network architecture correspond
to, you know,
considering considering
okay, well,
if you choose the palm DP architectures,
then we sometimes use
the gamma function to computer the
posterior expectation about parameters.
But in the neural network modeling
the gamma function doesn't appear but it
is replaced with the logarithm of some
function. And simply speaking,
the difference between the gamma
function of something and the logarithm
function of something is asymmetry
Lamme. So that's why we can transform
home DP two neural network
architectures. When the number of
samples is sufficiently large.
Which form do you expect performs
better under small or large amounts of
data? Well,
for large amount of data they work in
the same manner. Same manner.
For small amount
of examples, I'm not
truly sure but it
corresponds to assumptions about the
posterior belief distribution.
So if you assume delicious distribution
then your
resulting function form is something
that used the gamma function
in terms of basic inference probably
which is optimal.
All right, let's return to the earliest
questions from today.
So in
your script, which people can reference,
there's basically a toggle between
having it in SIM type one or SIM type
two corresponding to the POMDP
in the neural network. What about if
there's a published neural network or
POMDP? How can we use
this architecture to create
a translation?
Is there any difference in this? Kind of
like translating models in the wild
different than the full construction
of a special script that can speak
both languages?
Well, in terms of script there's
no difference,
sympathetic difference. Right.
So they work in
the same manner. So only a translation
of variable the
same source code in two different ways.
So if you see that this is a neural
network generation, then it
is translated as a neural network. Or if
you see that this is a POMDP, then it's
POMDP.
So for some neural network being used in
an industrial setting,
how would we get from the neural
network to a POMDP? And where
or how would that representation be
valuable? Right? So when
neural network in the different
architectures the important point
is that we consider a particular form of
neural network which is called canonical
neural network architecture. So only
when we assume this crossover
neural network then you can find
the exact correspondence to a particular
form of POMDP. Otherwise you
need to establish another equivalent
between another form of neural network
architectures and some sort of Bayesian
model. This may
be expressed by POMDP, but maybe
not so straightforward to be expressed
as the computational AP architectures.
So what is it about the canonical neural
network architecture that facilitates
its translation into the POMDP form?
Yeah, first of all, it assumes sigmoid
or activation function. It is nicely
correspond to enthralpy time in the
force DP equations from DP formulations.
So that's why we can
clear marketing. So yeah, in other
words, simply speaking, they have
the same nonlinearity. That's why this
translation is very easy with
another nonlinearity or neural network
equation, then we need
to find another type of entropy
equation or another type of prior
distribution. It is very nontrivial.
How does one even go about doing
that research?
If you want to go
that direction, then I think the first
step is to find the prior
brief, which makes the
prior brief and find the
equivalence between a particular neural
network architectures and particular
Bayesian model.
This sigmoidal activation is
interesting. It corresponds to
general patterns seen in psychophysics,
like two objects that are the same
weight. You're going to have a chance of
saying that one is heavier and then
initially the difference has the most
returns on that decision
being made accurately.
And then as it crosses some threshold
where it just is beyond a noticeable
difference, the decision becomes
essentially probabilistic, like the
firing curve becomes saturated,
the neuron chaos, a very low belief
about zero or very high belief about
zero or one flip that.
So there is a nice grounding
of that kind of a sigmoidal response
curve with respect to stimuli
differences and it has of course,
tractable analytical properties,
but it also just happens to be a good
response summarizer. Yeah,
you're right. So sigmoidar function is
also known as a psychometric function,
as you say. We observe that
characteristic in many psychical
experiments. And the previous work also
said that even
at the single neuron level, neuronal
level, the same behavior were absorbed,
which means that each heuristic
we can reobserve the similar
property, which is sometimes called
as neurometric function,
which is which have the form of sigmoida
activation function.
So it is nice reason
to design
neural network architecture using a
sigmoid or function.
All right, let's cover a few questions
in the chat from Dave and then in the
end turn to some general thoughts.
Okay, this was when we were looking at
figure three. So you described
these vectors
or matrices. What kind of matrix or
vector did you describe? The mass block
matrix. Block matrix.
Block rock learning
what? Okay, rock matrix of rock.
Vector is a vector vector or matrix
of matrix. So imagine that.
Sorry, just zoom, just glitch just
repeat the last piece. Okay,
well, broke matrix Dean that the
element of matrix is a matrix.
So let's say two by two matrix like
matrix in the ear pointing.
So this here W one hat
is a matrix and W zero
hat is another matrix. And combining
four matrices, we define a single
block matrix. All right,
thank you. So Dave
then asks the hosts of Machine Learning
Street Talk Number 67 with Karl
Friston. Another podcast, Karl Friston
has spoken. Pressed Karl Friston
on why is it so important that most of
the values in a generative model matrix
assume values of exactly zero?
Why is it important that generative
model matrices are sparse?
Why?
I'm not Bull sure. I think there is some
context before that point.
I think on that particular situation,
then, yeah, as you say, the many
elements in the matrix or gentle model
should be zero, but I'm not sure if it's
a general statement at all.
What do you think about compressed
analyses on sparse matrices?
Is that a useful technique or
direction?
You can use that knowledge to
construct model, so you
can use that knowledge to make more
accurate inference. So in that sense,
generally speaking, such assumptions
should be useful.
For example, yeah, as you said,
it would be possible to use some sparse
prior to restrict
the value of parameter. Like, it is in
principle same as assuming some L
one norm to design the
distribution. To design the prior
distribution, which is mass Dutch
speaking. Exactly same as considering
Lasso regression.
Yes. So we've
explored a little bit how from a
canonical neural network to a particular
form of a POMDP, gives us
some semantics and interpretability
around the dynamics and plasticity of
the neural network. What do we gain
by taking a stated POMDP
generative model and deriving an
analogous neural network?
Do we gain access to efficient
computation, new software packages,
different applications?
Well, if one use Home DP
and one's goal is
so design an efficient basic model,
then I think your Home DP expression
is sufficient. So you
don't need to consider neural network
architecture,
probably because Homedippy
architecture and Bayesian correlation is
designed to achieve some sort of
mathematically optimal inference
and decision making. Right? So it itself
is optimal scheme.
But if one need to
consider a link between Bayesian
inference and biological substrates,
then this mapping is crucial.
Simply speaking, we consider that
we assume that a brain perform Beijing
inference, but its substrate is still
unclear. So we need to link the
Bayesian quantity to biological
quantities. So this mapping, this
equivalent, helps us to its
translation. Right? So when you
start from on the model, then this
translation facilitates the process
of finding its neuronal substrate.
So once you translate that to a basic to
neural network quantities, then it
facilitates the experimental
validation application to
reality. So if its
modeling is apt
for a particular neural network neural
circuit architecture, then it
should provide some prediction about the
architecture or dynamics of the
empirical data.
Right? So first we start from Bayesian
model, which is not necessary to be
equal to empirical data. So there
is some mapping, but it's mapping is
not straightforward. We may have
multiple mappings, but once you
translate Bayesian model to a particular
neural network architectures then
mapping or relationship between
applicable data to such a particular
neural network model is straightforward.
So it helps us to apply base
to an explanation of MP card
data.
So is it fair to say that neural
networks have found wide recent
application because they facilitate
statistical learning in cases where the
inference problem has not been a priori
well specified? One can just have a
folder of images and a list of
labels and just say, here's the
data. Run it through this architecture
or this architecture Explorer.
And so with this concordance we
gain new interpretation into those
settings that kind of arose from ill
specified inference problems. And then
on the other hand, for problems that we
already have well specified in terms of
a POMDP generative model of a particular
form, we gain
the connection to actually implement it
with empirical data and
bring it into relevant industrial
settings.
What systems or phenomena are
promising to continue research on the
image example obviously is a simple
case, but are you continuing research
into more advanced computational agents?
Robotic animal.
Oh, hello can
design a more sophisticated
agent which performs some difficult
tasks based on canonical
network neural network but
there is some limitation, clear
limitation on that direction.
Right? So yeah, I should emphasize
that across the canonical neural network
which correspond to a particular home DP
is much smaller than general
home DP framework. So there
are some limitations, a least of
limitations. So if one's goal
is designed and sophisticated DAGs
to perform some task or control robot,
then one direction is just
forget such limitations and
take the mathematical optimality right
and another direction is barrelscale
probability. So if one wants to image
some agent which is barely possible,
then this correspondence is crucial
because it tells us biological
limitations through the
existence, no existence of such a
mapping between POMDP and particular
neural network architectures. So,
yeah. So it would be useful to consider
a vertical substrate to achieve
exafferent task.
And that task would be related to high
dimension image processing.
Image recognition or sound recognition,
such as multimodality, can be inbox
or decision. Can be higher dimensional
like in the mainstays,
we just consider the four directional
movement, but it can be extended to
higher dimensionality,
like arm movement, body movement,
so on, so on. So in principle it
can be extended in that direction.
Which directions or questions
are you excited about? Or what areas
of studying the basis
of biological and computational
intelligence are relevant? Yes.
So in terms of
the importance of canonical network, as
you said,
virtue is a biological probability.
So it would be nice that if
we model some task which is
conducted by learning and
one already recorded some neural
activity, then we
design a task which is
exactly same as the task which is done
by the animal and then compare
the simulated agent and Mpcar data
to discuss about the similarity or
difference between the
simulated agent and the animals.
That would be very interesting direction
of research.
Yeah, and if there could be some
unexpected prediction or explanation in
the computational agent, that would
bolster the relationship. And then
one other aspect is it
would help with the reproducibility and
the documentation around behavior
studies if the computational
agent were preregistered and someone
said we've already done the statistical
power analysis and we've already
explored with parameter sweeps how
many observations we need to make of
the two armed bandit. How many
observations of the three armed bandit
should we do? Three mice 100 times or
100 mice three times? Those are
the total substance of designing
research programs. And so
having a formal representation of
behavioral tasks that are being studied
will help us design behavior
observations and experiments that aren't
simply ad hoc.
All right, that's an interesting
application.
This framework helps to design the
experimental setup itself.
And what we often consider is
the prediction ability of these modern
canonical neural networks to predict the
Jelle phoneization or dynamics of
the VR neural network in the animal
during the learning process. So in
place for it is possible to predict the
behavior after learning based only on
data in the initial
stage because once we obtain
some empirical data, then we can fit
that data to design a particular
canonical network. And canonical neural
network makes some correlation
through a minimization cost function
which is exactly same as the Bayesian
belief updating under a particular
guarantee model. So which means that its
dynamics goes through the shortest path
on the free energy landscape which means
that we can make some quantitative
prediction about the sinatic trajectory
or neural activity or any
kind of parameters. So we demonstrated
that using in virtual neural network
and uploaded some footprint recently.
So at the stage, at least at
the level in vitro network,
which is much simpler than VR brain, we
could predict the self organization
of in virtual network using
this canonical network architecture and
this support the probability of
free energy principle because this
canonical network predict the
communication through the variational
free energy minimization and its
solution. Its results have a very
tight correlation between correlation
to Archer synchronization.
That's a very interesting experiment.
So what animal
were the neurons from and what was
measured about these neurons? Yes,
so that in vitro network is
obtained from blood embryo,
we use cortical cells to
make that individual network and
task is sort of causal inference
task which can be designed in the form
of OMDP. So imagine that
we usually simulate agents that receive
signals generated by OMDP generative
process and process and Beijing task.
So we just replaced that Bayesian agent
to neural network.
So we stimulate neuron with some signal
which is made by some hidden sources
through like a human mapping and
question is whether in viral network can
info the hidden states through some
communication and they can they could
Ines the hidden culture.
What does it look like functionally when
the neural network has succeeded at
inferring the hidden causes? Yeah,
the direct conversation is done by the
response number response spikes to a
particular pattern sensory input.
So again, we can see a clear
correspondence between activity level
and posterior belief about hidden state.
So here we see re a book response
to an electropaste memory.
We see the response from ten
to 13 milliseconds after each
stimulation and we compute the number of
spikes and that spikes changes
their preference in
the sense that some neurons learn
to preferentially respond to force one
but not source two. So which is not
a response to input itself, but it
looks like a response to particular
source. So it is inference
which is empirical evidence that
neural network actually perform some
sort of causal inference in
a manner consistent with traditional
Bayesian inference. And then we compute
another quantity in Bayesian inference
in the real vertical data.
We show that firing
special factor is consistent with
the prior belief about hidden states and
we also compute the synaptic rate
statistically through some connection
strength estimation method and show that
the estimated
synaptic strength is consistent with
something encoding posterior
belief about parameters, as expected by
the theory.
Well, we looked at table two earlier
and this is almost like the next step
after the theoretical concordance is
all right, well, let's measure the
release of a neurotransmitter or the
empirical synaptic strength or the
firing threshold or all these different
features in different empirical systems.
So what experimental
systems does your group work in?
That in virtual system was made
when I was a PhD student. So that
is experiment we done in
my previous route and now I
COVID to the Bijan Institute and
I'm a Princepal investigator
of Celery unit. So now actually we
don't use any experimental setup,
so any experimental bidding is
down with some collaboration. So
although I cannot say detail about that
exploration. But yeah, we learn some
collaborating work about the implication
of salary using various
animals. Yeah, so we hope we
can show some interesting results
following results using animal data.
Very interesting.
Yeah, well, it speaks a lot to the stage
that our field is in in certain
ways where we've
seen a lot of graphics that
are suggestive. This paper
and the building on the previous 2020
paper made a suggestive
possibility much closer
to an analytically
demonstrated translation and then
took the next step incrementally into
the in silico agent. And so it's only
natural to then explore different
embodied systems as well.
Are there any other sections that you
wanted to like, look at or highlight or
any other topics about the paper or
adjacencies or active inference that
you think are interesting to go into?
Yeah, okay,
I would like to mention about some
implication of these papers, which is
not the director discussing the papers.
So for example,
well, we focus on a
discrete state space model.
So we avoid
to assume some subscript that encodes
the coherence of
the distribution. So once you assume
homedp then it is categorical
distinctions. So it is different from
assuming Gaussian distribution
characterized by me and variants. So the
neural substrate of variance is
still unclear and we now try to
figure out that. So this is one
direction of limitation and another
implication is that thanks to a simple
ODP structure in this paper,
we don't care about the
hierarchical optimization.
But generally it is crucial to
update parameters through hierarchical
optimization through some
backpropagation like computation.
Although it is unclear whether back
propagation itself occurred in the real
brain. But we still have some
alternative that achieve such
optimization and it's neural substrate
still unclear and this paper doesn't
address that direction.
Another area I'm wondering about is like
where in neural structures is
the learning reflected? Where is
the function and learning reflected?
Well, sometimes it has to do with not
just structural Tweaking,
but the presence or absence of synapses.
So obviously this model does not expand
into synaptogenesis synaptic pruning,
let alone neurogenesis and neuro
allostasis which we mentioned in the
previous discussion. But understanding
how these larger scale structural
changes which are certainly important in
biological systems become reflected in
artificial neural networks and then how
that translates all the way back to
P-O-M. DP and then whether we could go
the other way. What kinds of POMDP
structures in their neural network
realization would have structural
modification. Like you COVID imagine a
POMDP that does
structure learning but the neural
network doesn't have structural change.
Or there's A-P-O-M DP that doesn't do
structural learning but it's manifested
by a neural network that does have a
structural change element. So structure
is doing something very different in
these two different categories of model.
And then also even within
neural firing, which is
different amongst different species and
so on, there's different aspects
of what that firing is that would have
different implications for the actual
biological substrate of cognition niche.
The simple connection is firing
rate to posterior belief.
Average firing rate, no change in
posterior. Reduce the firing rate if the
posterior should be going down.
Increase it if it should be going up.
Or maybe there are neurons that have a
flipped valence but the same type of
relationship, but there's other firing
patterns like spike
time dependent plasticity
synchronization amongst different brain
regions. There's a lot of things that
don't change the rate overall.
That again from the biological systems
we know that those phenomena and
mechanism are important for different
cognitive processes.
So there will be many many years
of a fruitful relationship.
I'm going to bring in this picture
that Alexandra had taken.
Maybe we need a third panel in
figure one because
these three systems moving between them
is going to be the substance of the
field for a long time and there may be
other edges to build. But understanding
how artificial neural networks
intermediate between the empirical
measurements and manipulations that we
can make of real neural systems and
the interpretability and
factorizability of POMDPs it
might be a bridge too far to go from the
POMDP to the neuron. You could always
use this technique but it would be a
purely descriptive statistic type
approach. But it's
so interesting that by intermediating
through a formal connection
established in figure one I Dean in
equation one but also shown here,
then we can kind of extend the
chain of exploration, prediction,
control, design all the way
on through. And that just unlocks
like an incredible amount of
neuroscience that hasn't been formalized
mathematically and an incredible
amount of generative models that
have been specified for different
learning settings sometimes even by
analogy to biological settings.
But the metaphor remains just a metaphor
until it's possible to intermediate with
this type of neural network development.
Yeah, that's a crucial point.
It is easy to imagine that phenomena
can be modeled using very realistic
neural model or free model synaptic
model. Right.
We believe that it is possible and then
Laje model is not necessarily tractable,
not necessarily useful because it's too
much complicated to analyze something.
So we use some reduction, usually
mathematically speaking, which
correspond to topological transformation
to make the model simpler.
And then we need to consider the
translation of that simplified neural
network model because neural network
model itself is not explainable
which just represents some dynamics and
its functional meaning is not clear.
But thanks to the Bayesian framework we
have a very nice event framework
to least the experiment ability.
And this translation, this
correspondence helped us to link such
a phenomena base equation
modeling and functional base
equations. Yeah, one paper
from 2017 that was
much discussed by some could a
neuroscientist understand a
microprocessor? And this
group with Jonas and Courting, they had
a simulation of a microprocessor
from an earlier video game console,
I believe. And then using the analogy
of like the transistors and their
connections as neural firing and
structural connectivity they were able
to simulate experimental settings,
input and action and then make
measurements from every neuron including
doing lesions and loss of functions and
so on. And it turns out that a lot of
the techniques that are used to derive
scientific explanation from analogous
data collected from a biological system,
those techniques which ostensibly should
be isolating functional explanations in
fact did not isolate effective
exploration. You could have a deletion
over here that induces some statistical
change all the way over here and that
may or may not be a useful clue towards
the function of even subcircuits.
And so I think that was a wake up call
with respect to the interpretability of
simply this connection
between the biological and the neural
network. This connection
alone is of limited
applicability even when the
neural network model becomes so complex
as to recapitulate the biological
phenomena, you're never under
any guarantee that you're going to
recover interpretability. You may have
just created an atomic level simulation
of the phenomena, but of course, a map
that is the same scale as the phenomena
isn't a map. It's just a copy that has
no more interpretability.
And it's almost like what
is now extended again, as we kind of
just summarize this and think about how
we move forward, is that connection
can now be extended into the space
of interpretable causal models and the
generalized Bayesian graphical
computational frameworks and all the
heuristic that we can then use like
variational, Bayes and all these other
methods. So it'd be interesting to look
back at different data sets of in
vitro and in vivo and in silico neural
activation, especially if
the task was of this constrained
set of POMDPs and
it was already amenable. Because, as you
brought up, other settings would require
a little bit more theory development
before we understand what POMDP family
would be applicable.
Cool. Well, do you have any final
thoughts or questions?
Well, do you hop.
I kant to download the MATLAB scripts
and generate the figures,
play around with a few of these
parameters? Like, I see that you can
change how far the entity can see.
And then with these models, I'm also
always curious about the computational
complexity. Like if you extended the
planning horizon from four to five or
you dropped it down to three,
what is the runtime consequences and
what is the performance consequences?
And where might we be able to use single
or swarms of really simple
agent, maybe even making binary
decisions and achieve
high performance? And where
do we really need to move into
these large combinatoric spaces
in order to solve problems and the
kinds of complex planning problems that
we solve, whether it's planning our day
or planning our week,
are those force like true
Deep Harrison planning problems with
extensive consideration of
counterfactuals and calculation of
alternatives? Or are those actually
composite decisions that are
made up of smaller,
simpler, sub decisions that
we may or may not have flexibility to
restructure? So that
a decision, a complex
chess maneuver, a sacrifice in chess or
another game. It may be
possible to model that as a Deep Horizon
scan or a kind
of intuitive heuristic for
an appropriate skilled entity.
For this particular two Brea structure,
there is a clear limitation about the
horizon forward
because it doesn't use forward
prediction, it used post action
approach. So it's a clear limitation,
but still, it may have some performance
ability, active, some levels of
affordance.
That provides even another way
to look at planning. The two
ways I was describing planning, as it's
often described in the PMDP literature
is again, is it a true Deep Horizon
consideration or is it just short term
heuristics or nested models that are
short? And I think that this
paper says maybe neither.
Maybe it's purely the
active causality on the past that
leads to the emergence of sentient and
maybe even teleological planninglike
behavior through the ongoing
reconsideration of the consequences of
least action. But it's neither a short
nor a long term planning challenge.
It's actually like a memory and learning
challenge. And no planning occurs.
Right. Indirect planning
planning element is involving C matrix.
Planning as a phenomenon occurs and
derisking through time occurs.
But it says something quite
interesting and deep that that phenotype
or function could be enacted by
a system that explicitly looks a long
way ahead, explicitly looks a short way
ahead or moves forward and
looks backwards only, right, which is
what they sometimes say about the past
and the future.
So that may be a very
biologically plausible form
of learning. And it's
already intimately connected with the
dynamics and the activity in terms of
an integrated loss function.
So these are all excellent directions
to keep learning on. Right?
And I'm also interested in the barrel
implementation of such a short term or
long term for the prediction and
running. And I hope to find
some nice connectivity to such
implementation of Bayesian motor and
implementation in VR brain network.
Cool. And also I'm always curious about
the invertebrate brain as an
ant researcher. And so many of
the brain architectures as
well as the brain architecture that
people discuss are mammalian centric,
which makes sense. The mammalian
cortical column and the relationship
with Dopaminergic midbrain and the
cortical regions and the spinal reflex
arc those are all important systems of
interest. Yet the micro
and meso anatomy of the invertebrate
nervous system is pretty distinct.
So our model should be able to describe
neural and cognitive systems, of course,
across invertebrates and vertebrates.
So I look forward to also seeing what
those models of the invertebrate nervous
system and collective behavior where
you could have some type of backwards
looking risk inference
of the swarm. Who knows?
Well. We really
appreciate the time that you took for
these discussions. I think they are
immensely important. And we wish you the
best of luck in these continued
directions.
Yes.
Okay, that's it. Thank you. Thank you
very much. See you next time.